Classroom technology has prompted dramatic
promises that computers will revolutionize
learning, and dire warnings of what might
ensue.
What both camps share is the tendency to take
the march of technology as a given.
But in an unexpected twist, a recent international
analysis shows that elementary students used
less classroom technology in 2016 than a decade
before.
In 2006, three-quarters of U.S. 4th graders
said they “used computers at school at least
once a week.”
By 2016, that figure had declined markedly.
What this means isn’t entirely
clear.
Are students simply using phones instead of
computers?
Has the meaning of “use a computer” simply
changed over time?
Or, are schools moving to restrict the use
of technology?
That’s all up for debate.
My takeaway?
That it’s always useful to check our grand
education narratives against the prosaic facts.
And that the facts themselves aren’t always
as straightforward as we  might wish.
Do you think students are using less technology today than they were a decade ago?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our shcolars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.